plus loin qui continue place aux matchs
des idées confrontation de points de vue
ce soir entre gabriel syrie où harry et
laurent hénart on va notamment s'arrêter
sur la campagne des élections régionales
qui commence à se mettre en place avec
ses têtes d'affiché alliant ces attaques
en paca le président sortant renaud
muselier tentés par une alliance avec en
marche
en bourgogne franche comté et l'air
roulerait avec dupont dupont aignan en
ile de france julien bayou signal
valérie pécresse à la commission des
comptes de campagne élections régionales
coup d'envoi des hostilités on va en
parler avec nos invités après les
détails de jérôme vallier moins de deux
mois avant le scrutin les partis
commencent à peine à se mettre en ordre
de marche pour les régionales côté
majorité présidentielle on aborde le
scrutin sans grand espoir de conquête
les ministres lrm et modem seront
présents en force en tête de liste
régionale comme marc fesneau ou sophie
cluzel ou en soutien sur les listes
départementales comme marlène schiappa à
paris pour espérer s'imposer ou
s'implanter des alliances sont envisagés
avec les républicains mais la question
divise la majorité qui préfèrent envoyer
les accords à plus tard
moi je ne profite pas de ces questions
d'alliances de second tour et
d'équilibrage voit bien qu un certain
nombre de gens font des listes avec
cette préoccupation ma préoccupation
c'est de sortir en tête et ma
préoccupation c'est d'offrir aux
habitants une alternative à ce débat qui
que certains voudraient construire et de
faire en sorte qu'une nouvelle majorité
sortent de la région et donc c'est les
électeurs qui décideront de ce qui se
passe le soir du premier tour et plus
nous placerons au plus on sera en
situation pouvoir gagner chez les
républicains et leurs alliés on tentera
de consolider les acquis
si laurent wauquiez ou valérie pécresse
ne sont pas encore officiellement
candidat
renaud muselier et xavier bertrand sont
déjà en course
la droite et certains de ses leaders
rêve de faire de cette élection un
tremplin pour 2022
à gauche et la question de l'union qui
occupe les esprits pour l'instant seuls
écologistes karima delli dans les hauts
de france a réussi à réunir l'ensemble
des forces de gauche derrière sa
candidature au ps on tentera de
conserver ses positions
mais les écologistes veulent leur
contester le leadership
ils partiront donc seul dans de
nombreuses régions au rassemblement
national on espère cette année réussir à
emporter au moins une région
thierry mariani fait office de
challenger sérieux en provence alpes
côte d'azur où l'extrême droite avait
échoué 2
en 2015 notamment grâce à un front
républicain qui a peu de chances de se
reproduire cette année pour tous ces
candidats est ce pas encore déclaré la
date limite est fixée au 17 mai pour
déposer sa candidature avant une
campagne inédite sans grand meeting
situation sanitaire oblige avec nous
pour le match des idées ce soir gabriel
syrie où harry bienvenue vous êtes
économiste porte parole du parti
socialiste adjointe au maire du xviiie
arrondissement de paris laurent hénard
bienvenu au également vous êtes
président du mouvement radical et
conseils conseiller municipal annonce y
juste avant que vous entriez sur ce
plateau je donnais trois exemples de
régions où la campagne battait déjà son
plein avec les hostilités qui vont avec
est ce que vous diriez laurent hénart
que la crise kobe n'a rien changé aux
pratiques et aux hostilités politiques
qui se lance à chaque campagne
oui je suis pas sûr que ça ait provoqué
une retenue républicaine si c'est ça
votre question le vrai sujet mon avis
d'ailleurs il est pas là il est quand
même de voir qu'on n'a pas pris les
mesures pour permettre le vote à
distance
moi je suis en lorraine je suis voisins
par exemple de l'allemagne qui est un
pays qui organisait depuis plus d'un an
plusieurs scrutins locaux à l'échelle
des länder aussi avec le vote par
correspondance avec du coup un électeur
sur deux dans certains länder comme la
bavière qui ont voté par correspondance
je dis ça pourquoi est-ce qu'on a tous
vu l'effondrement de la participation
municipale la déformation que ça
provoque bien sûr du scrutin et puis le
fait qu'une partie de la population se
sent empêcher d'agir on sait tous que
évidemment elles ce sont les les
personnes à risque qui ont hésité à
aller voter en mars et encore en juin où
la participation ne s'est quasiment pas
améliorée vont regretter qu'elles soient
maintenues ces engins non je dis
justement parce que honnêtement on
aurait eu le temps en 1 an d'étudier le
vote par correspondance qui existe
d'ailleurs il existe pour les publics
détenus
il existe pour des élections
professionnelles qui font voter des
millions de personnes donc il existe
j'ai pour les français de l'étranger
donc il existe en france et il est
pratiqué dans des démocraties autour de
nous je reviens pas sur l'exemple de la
présidentielle américaine et des votes à
distance des votes anticipés qui ont été
organisés et qui ont permis quand même
une participation de très bonne tenue
alors que la crise sanitaire était
dramatique pourquoi je tends soupçons de
fraude qui vont avec aussi un oui
honnêtement
c'était la position effectivement de
donald trump mais vous ne m'en voudrez
pas de toujours donner raison donald
trump et là je trouve que à l'ère du
complotisme ambiant du tourisme ambiance
non seulement france aussi oui mais
quand vous regardez l'allemagne
l'autriche en europe des pays pratiquent
le vote à distance
même aux états unis je suis désolée la
fraude n'a pas été démontrée et pourtant
donald trump
il a annulé de soupçons de fraude il a
cumulé sur toutes les procédures
il a accumulé toutes les procédures et
ya pire que éventuellement une campagne
des complotistes sur les réseaux sociaux
sur le soupçon de fraude via le fait
qu'à une partie de la population qui
pense que on tire un trait sur elle
voilà quand on sait qu'elle aura du mal
à aller voter qu'elle n'hésitera qu'elle
n'ira pas elle s'est aussi quatre
peut-être des moyens qui lui permettrait
de participer et on ne les met pas en
place ce qui est une façon de leur dire
bah finalement votre vote est un vote de
second rang il nous intéresse peu il
nous intéresse moins je trouve qu'en
termes de climat républicain sais c'est
pas une bonne chose mais un problème de
participation c'est une prime aux
sortants c'est bien connu
gabriel syrie comme envoyée oui alors
monsieur je suis tout à fait d'accord
avec ce qui vient d'être dit à la fois
concernant l'adaptation des conditions
de vote ça a été dit si les pays bas le
portugal qui a organisé des passants des
élections récemment il ya la question
donc d'une vente à distance
et puis des procurations parce que
finalement on aurait pu permettre de
procurations par personne ça non plus ça
n'a pas été fait et nous c'est quelque
chose qu'on demande depuis longtemps
depuis un an on demande de l'adaptation
des conditions de vote et des conditions
de campagne parce que les problèmes qui
se posent pour le vote se pose aussi
pour la campagne donc là on est obligé
de déportés en ligne en fait toute une
partie de nos activités qu'on fait
traditionnellement en physique avec des
réunions en présentiel et c'est moins
efficace
non mais c'est surtout que c'est ce que
c'est ce qui vient d'être dit ça laisse
de côté une partie de la population
parce que la fracture numérique est une
réalité
donc on le fait là en ce moment même
pendant que je vous parle il ya un
événement en ligne sur les femmes les
plus touchées par l'aco vide sur la
plateforme ile-de-france en commun en
ile de france donc c'est des choses
qu'on fait bien sûr on s'adapte mais la
fracture numérique est une réalité et
ses problématiques très problématique de
ne pas avoir anticipé le sujet au niveau
du gouvernement puisse à un moment quand
même qu'il est sur la table des
élections régionales qui pourraient
ensuite déboucher sur un romaine
gouvernemental c'est ce que croit savoir
le figaro après les régionales le
spectre d'un dernier remaniement a titré
le journal un classique mais direz-vous
d'abord parce que pas mal de ministres
sont candidats mais aussi parce qu'une
nouvelle équipe pourrait projeter
emmanuel macron vers la présidentielle
laurent hénart il faudra il faudrait un
nouveau gouvernement peut être plus
resserré un gouvernement au combat pour
la présidentielle c'est un gouvernement
resserré c'est quand même resserré le
gouvernement resserré où serré ça fait
partie des marronniers en main trop de
ministres on va réduire le nombre
ce qui est sûr c'est qu'on va changer à
mon avis quand même de rythme sur la
gestion de la crise sanitaire fin on
voit bien que avec la vaccination avec
maman enfin des outils de dépistage
massif qui sont d'usagé facile est
largement disponible
on sait donner des outils pour vivre
avec le virus donc falloir reprendre
l'activité le plus possible il va
falloir aussi amortir le choc économique
et sociale et il va être dur donc on
peut imaginer effectivement que face à
cette nouvelle séquence de crise le
gouvernement ça juste moi ça me
choquerait pas en même temps je pense
qu' il n'y aura pas de changement
profond dans la ligne politique qui est
celle qui a été défini au moment de la
nomination de deux du premier ministre
jean castex mais une équipe de l'après
crise une équipe pour faire oublier les
ratés de la première part ça je suis pas
sûr qu'un remaniement suffisent à clore
le débat sur la gestion de la crise
sanitaire
en tout cas ce qui est sûr c'est que on
voit bien voilà il nous faut des outils
pour vivre peut-être même quelques
années avec le virus avec en plus le
problème des mutants qui nécessite de se
mettre à jour
à ces variants de virus nécessite de se
mettre à jour régulièrement sur la
vaccination nécessiteront peut-être de
reprendre des mesures sanitaires et des
protocoles si à des variants plus
résistants que d'autres à la vaccination
aujourd'hui on l'espère ou traitement
demain donc on peut imaginer qu'une
organisation gouvernementale soit plus
adapté à cette séquence
gabriel série houari bon bah écoutez je
sais pas si un manuel
aucun espoir particulier un remaniement
non mais là la ligne politique et pas du
tout en question alors on pourrait avoir
un sursaut sur la question de certains
ministres qui sont encore
scandaleusement en poste je pense à
gérald darmanin et on est la risée
d'ailleurs d'un certain nombre de pays
parce que c'est quand même une grande
première en france d'avoir un ministre
de l'intérieur accusé de viol qui est
toujours en poste
je crois pas que ce soit l'intention
forcément des manuels macron de changer
son gouvernement aujourd'hui il l'a fait
la dernière fois
notamment parce que son premier ministre
était en train de devenir peut-être
dangereusement populaire je sais pas
s'il a fait le bon choix d'ailleurs de
l'écarter parce que maintenant d'un
philippe en profite pour laisser planer
le doute sur sa propre candidature
je sais pas si le même sujet je crois
pas se poser avec jean castex jeu je
vois pas un voile à un remaniement
particulièrement à l'ordre du jour mais
sauf pour changer les ministres
effectivement candidat mais il faut
rappeler quand même qu'ils ont assez peu
de chances de remporter les régions
parce qu'en marche souffre toujours du
même problème
dire qu'ils sont très très peu implantés
localement on l'a vu aux dernières
municipales
ils ont des résultats qui sont
catastrophiques aux élections locales
il faudrait de raison particulière pour
que ça change au niveau régional autre
sujet ce soir le discours de joe biden
devant le congrès c'est dans tout juste
quelques heures on sait déjà qu'il va
mettre le paquet sur la fiscalité des
plus riches pour financer son plan de
relance de 1800 milliards de dollars il
veut notamment annulé les baisses
d'impôts pour les plus riches voté sous
donald trump s'attaquer aux niches
fiscales dont il bénéficie sur le plan
économique on en a parlé hier sur ce
plateau on sait que les états unis
partent aussi de très loin sur le plan
fiscal et social
mais quel impact sur le politique sur le
plan politique ici en france à caen chez
nous la même chose a écrit tout à
l'heure avec un peu d'ironie
la sénatrice esther benbassa sur twitter
by donne fait rêver
la gauche française vous me direz
d'ailleurs si vous êtes d'accord avec ça
on va en parler d'abord avec emmanuel
rivière qu'on accueille dans ce match
des idées bienvenue manuel vous êtes
directeur international pour les études
politiques de kantar publique depuis
quatre ans emmanuel macron a promis de
ne pas augmenter les impôts il a réformé
lier ses fils a été qualifié de
président des riches
est ce que cette révolution un peu
inattendu de joe biden pourrait porter
un coup sérieux à son image en tout cas
c'est vrai que les choses ont changé par
rapport à la référence qui référence
qu'est celle des états unis alors
c'était amusant nous entendre dire
bailon fait rêver parce que c'est pas
exactement comme ça qu'on le voyait il
ya seulement halleguen seulement un
point et il arrive d'abord par contraste
avec donald trump donald trump était la
figure honnie en france d'ailleurs très
largement dans toutes les catégories
politiques ou presque donc maiden aux
frais essentiellement les avantages de
n'être pas trump rien à voir avec
l'élection de barack obama qui était un
symbole pour beaucoup d'ailleurs
d'occidentaux et pas simplement et
beaucoup d'ailleurs de l'opinion
publique dans dans le monde sauf que là
il surconsommant de dubaï donne en étant
finalement sur un terrain il a attendu
la coqueluche de la gauche française
dans les élections primaires démocrates
c'est plutôt bernie sanders et là on a
une politique qui vaut pour pour
l'exemple et c'est là où effectivement
ça peut changer un petit peu la donne
parce que un des points forts de la de
raisonnement non seulement des partis
politiques et des décideurs politiques
mais y compris dans le client public
c'est à dire qu'est ce qui se passe
ailleurs qu'est ce qui est raisonnable
qu est-ce qui est qu'est ce qui est
possible
dire que ça peu ringard 10 et emmanuel
macron exerce une pression tout va
dépendre des des sujets il y en a un où
clairement l'opinion publique en france
est majoritairement aligné avec ce que
vous venez de rappeler c'est la
fiscalité des plus hauts revenus la
fiscalité des plus riches dont on attend
toujours qu'il soit remis à contribution
c'est un marqueur fort auquel il est
très attaché le gouvernement actuel
d'avoir allégé cette fiscalité dans une
perspective d'attractivité du pays
notamment
et là c'est vrai que ça va jouer parce
que quand on parle d'attractivité du
pays on est forcément dans un
raisonnement en comparaison et lorsque
al'inverse on parlait de cette fuite des
cerveaux qui justifiait de revoir un
petit peu la manière on pense aligner ou
pas sur un certain nombre d'indicateurs
la fiscalité des plus hauts revenus
pouvoir en faire partie ça change la
donne ne savoir que de l'autre côté de
l'atlantique sa terre promise qui
semblait être salutaire d'attraction
justement les talents de ceux qui
voulaient construire lors leurs sociétés
créent leur société devenir millionnaire
pour reprendre une expression il
préservera public si ça change là bas si
le paradigme est différent alors
évidemment la question de l'attractivité
se pose plus de la même manière et en
quelques secondes et manuel est ce que
dans la france post qu'ovide ce n'est
pas ce qu'attendent les français c'est à
dire un leader fort qui annonce une aide
puissante public une aide de l'état
un état providence fort ceux là où il ya
une grosse nuance rien ne reprendrait
très intéressant qu'on réalise pour la
commission européenne qui a été publié
vendredi dernier et qui montre qu'il ya
des attentes très fortes et une
thématique qui marche très bien et en
france particulièrement kessel la
relocalisation la question les
territoires de l'aide aux agriculteurs
en revanche la notion de grand plan
d'investissements d'investissements
massifs publics dans l'économie
la france est très en retrait parmi les
derniers pays pourra prouver cela parce
que là dessus il ya une question et
caractéristiques du climat en france
c'est qu'il faut aussi avoir confiance
dans la puissance publique pour se dire
que ça vaut le coup d'investir des
milliards ou des dizaines de milliards
et quand on en aura le bénéfice c'est là
un peu où ce sera la démonstration par
la preuve
mais autant il ya une année il ya un
attrait et un intérêt pour ce qui
provoque joe biden sur la fiscalisation
des plus fortunés et des entreprises il
ya beaucoup moins d'attrait en france
que dans d'autres pays européens sur le
mécanisme est le principe du grand plan
investissement
d'accord c'est intéressant rester avec
nous et manuel on va commenter tout ce
que vous venez de dire sur ce plateau il
vous fait rêver baida à bas aujourd'hui
c'est vrai que c'est une source
d'inspiration indéniable en fait pour la
gauche d'ailleurs anne hidalgo en a
parlé ce matin sur france info
parce qu'effectivement je crois que je
vais y donne aujourd'hui fait quelque
chose d'assez fort c'est qui va à
l'encontre d'un certain nombre de dogmes
et d'idées reçues
on nous disait voilà l'imposition des
plus riches c'est dangereux parce qu'ils
vont fuir à l'étranger c'était
d'ailleurs un des arguments principaux
du gouvernement pour supprimer les sf
tout ça c'est pas attestée dans les
chiffres très peu de jeu de gens qui
quittent le pays à cause de l'imposition
et surtout la suppression de l' iss n'a
eu aucune conséquence positive sur
l'économie
et c'est pas moi qui le dit c'est le
rapport de france stratégie qui dépend
quand même du premier ministre
donc face à ces faits je crois que nous
on ferait bien aussi effectivement de
s'inspirer de ce qui est fait
outre-atlantique et de ce volontarisme
politique très fort qui vise d'abord à
ce qui a été dit réduire les inégalités
relancé par la consommation alors qu'on
est dans une période
évidemment très très compliqué pour un
certain nombre de
ménages que ce soit les classes
populaires mais aussi les classes
moyennes et donc oui nous on regarde
montre atlantique
l'espace est ce que fait déjà validée in
ne secoue pas que la gauche si laurent
hénart maiden ce qui n'est pas en train
de donner une leçon de socialisme au
monde entier notamment à l'europe
peut-être non je pense qu'il reprend
surtout des thématiques qui avant
étaient des thématiques plus tôt
européenne enfin qui s'inspire de
l'europe
il ya des débats qu'on en europe depuis
longtemps j'en prendrais 3 rapidement
que joe biden a annoncé aussi dans ses
champs d'exploration 1 le retour des
accords de paris il ouvre aussi la porte
à une fiscalité écologique
c'est quand même quelque chose qui est
arrivée avant tout dans le débat dans
les pays européens
2 il évoque et je pense que c'est plus
intéressant que les sf
il évoque l'idée qu' il faut mettre en
place un système où le travail n'est pas
plus taxé que le capital une justice
globale en fait du système fiscal
c'est aussi un des bacs et est arrivé en
europe que d'ailleurs on n'a pas réussi
à résoudre mais qui est un vrai débat
très juste sur lequel les radicaux par
exemple sont très engagés jeu c'est un
mouvement qu'il ya qui a inventé en son
temps l'impôt sur le revenu net choix
était attaché à la fiscalité progressive
et juste
le troisième sujet c'est la taxe tobin
face et l'idée que les grands mouvements
de capitaux de bénéfice de chiffre
d'affaires à l'échelle planétaire pour
éviter l'impôt là où il pèse un peu on
puisse les rattraper
on s'est quand même cette idée de la
taxe tobin sur les transactions
financières et quand il évoque un impôt
fin taux qui serait un taux
internationale sur l'imposition des
sociétés pour éviter justement ces
délocalisations de chiffre d'affaires
généralement d'ailleurs fictive au sens
où les emplois ne bouge pas forcément
l'activité ne bouge pas forcément mais
on déplace en fait l'argent produit par
cette activité d'un pays on juge la
fiscalité trop forte vers un autre pays
où elle est beaucoup plus accueillante
est beaucoup plus légère je crois que ça
aussi c'est des vrais débats et moi je
trouve très bien pour les européens que
et puis c'est peut-être maintenant avoir
un allié américain pour aller sur cette
fiscalité juste cette fiscalité
coordonnée et harmonisée à l'échelle
mondiale au moins un minimum et puis
cette fiscalité qui doit bien sûr porter
la transition écologique
dernière question emmanuel est ce que un
candidat à la présidentielle pourra
encore dire encore promettre comme
l'avait fait d'ailleurs françois fillon
en son temps il va falloir se serrer la
ceinture serait inutile parce que il ya
un an sans doute lorsque l'on pensait
lorsqu on espérait qu'il traversait une
crise très brusque eux mais dont on
pourrait sortir à assez vite y avait
peut-être une disponibilité à lire il
faut il faut faire des efforts il ya
peut-être des ajustements auxquels on
peut consentir là en fait énormément de
lassitude dans l'opinion publique les
gens ont vraiment le sentiment d'avoir
passé une année dure cumulation
d'inquiétude de frustration de privation
de conditions de travail difficiles on
publie demain avec une enquête comme a
réalisé avec la cfdt qui détaillera très
très bien tout cela est donc leur
disponibilité à dire ah ben oui là on se
retrouve c'est les manches comme une
espèce de d'efforts voilà l'économie de
post guerre en fait les gens elle s'en
sont assez peu disponible il respire
beaucoup à retrouver un peu de normalité
aussi lorsque cela sera difficile de
tenir ce discours là dans le temps qui
va nous séparer de la présidentielle et
on aura l'occasion d'en reparler
ensemble sur public sénat merci emmanuel
d'avoir été avec nous dans ce match des
idées on va parler sécurité violences
urbaines maintenant puisque c'était au
coeur d'une visite
gérard larcher aujourd'hui dans le rhône
à l'invitation du sénateur françois noël
buffet qui est par ailleurs président de
la commission des lois ici au sénat le
président du sénat rencontré des élus il
a rencontré les forces de l'ordre il a
participé à une table ronde sur les
violences contre les maires et il a
évoqué les problèmes d'insécurité en
général dans le pays je voudrais qu'on
l'écouté on en parle après sécurité
s'était produit l'année 2010 le fallait
pour eux depuis l'année 2000 a été moins
difficile
elle est démolie il faut qu'on apporte
des réponses fort la porte des réponses
etc les gens sales c'est une république
qui fait c'est une règle est qu'il est
juste mais faible ait eu ou pas farid et
laurent hénart cqn république ferme
juste mais ferme
alors moi je pense que il faut
sauvegarder d'empiler les dispositifs
législatifs suis pas sûr que il fallut
une grande loi pour que la république
soit enfin ferme et juste
je pense qu'il faut surtout programmée
des moyens alors c'est plus mon
expérience municipale à nancy où mon
travail d'avocat qui me font dire que
aujourd'hui 6 à 10 fonctionnent
globalement parce que c'est vrai que ça
dysfonctionne ça il faut l'admettre sur
le constat oui c'est un constat plus
largement une entrée de gérard larcher
on a du mal à
à garantir la sécurité du quotidien
auprès de nos concitoyens pourquoi parce
qu'on fait un effort quand même sans
précédent pour le terrorisme plutôt
contre le terrorisme depuis 2015
ça mobilise des moyens il faut bien
l'admettre et puis que et puis qu'en
plus on a trop tardé à mettre des moyens
sur la justice particulièrement aussi
sur la police ou la gendarmerie
à un moment donné il faut une loi de
programmation des moyens je prends deux
exemples très concrets un souvent les
gens s'émeuvent en disant ah là là il ya
eu un simple rappel à la loi pour ce
mineur qui pourtant avait fait l'objet
d'un flagrant délit certes mais si le
juge n'a pas de place en centre éducatif
fermé
s'il n'a pas assez de chantiers
d'intérêt général qui sont des mesures
adaptées pour les mineures plus que
quand même les placer dans une prison ou
de droit commun où la promiscuité risque
plutôt de l'est quant au désir de les
encourager dans leur vie ce que de les
leur proposer faire autre chose leur
donne envie de faire autre chose si on
n'a pas ces outils qui sont prévues par
la loi maintenant depuis plus de dix ans
pour depuis 20 ans 30 ans pour les
chantiers d'intérêt général mais
forcément qu'est ce qui fait bien il a
tendance à relâcher géré on a
aujourd'hui on est victime d'un manque
de moyens et moi si j'ai une demande à
faire c'est peut-être que qu'on fasse le
minimum de loi mais que peut-être toutes
les formations politiques républicaines
se mettent d'accord sur de loi de
programmation une pour la police la
gendarmerie et la sécurité intérieure et
une pour notre justice pour qui la
situation est franchement la plus
dramatique moi je vous invite à regarder
le nombre d'euro par habitant consacré à
la justice et à la magistrature en
france et regarder les chiffres en
allemagne en italie en angleterre en
espagne les autres grands pays européens
sincèrement on est à la moitié par
fournées entières donc des moyens c'est
le soir de la fermeté les deux vont
ensemble et san antonio mais en fait moi
ce qui me frappe beaucoup c'est toujours
ce discours de la droite qui est repris
ici par monsieur larcher et fermeté
ferme et et fermeté c'est de la
rhétorique derrière effectivement s'il
n'a pas les effectifs pour appliquer si
vous voulez la fermeté mais on se prive
de mots est aujourd'hui moi j'insiste
sur le fait que la création de postes de
policiers aujourd'hui c'est la gauche
principalement et ça arrange en réalité
est telle à gauche donc en fait c'est
cet écart me frappe
entre cette espèce d'occupation du
terrain sur le sujet de la sécurité
mais qui est vraiment très liées à une
espèce de de rhétorique 1 et puis la
réalité des chiffres derrière donc par
exemple la police de proximité ça a été
créée sous jospin supprimés sous nicolas
sarkozy
et aujourd'hui on voit que madame
pécresse veut faire sa campagne sur la
question de la sécurité alors déjà un
super une compétence régionale bon et
ensuite deux fins son mentor la première
chose qu'il a faite sur le sujet c'était
supprimé la police de proximité
donc oui créations de postes dans la
police nous a paris on a un renforcement
qui est prévue de la police municipale
avec des effectifs qui vont être très
fortement renforcées que ça va passer de
2000 à quatre mille cinq cents policiers
municipaux d'ici 2024 et évidemment dans
des d'un des arrondissements aussi comme
les nôtres moi je suis élu du xviiie
arrondissement
c'est quelque chose qui est qui est
important est d'ailleurs il ya toute une
partie du travail qui doit reposer sur
la police nationale et on demande
régulièrement des effectifs
supplémentaires de police nationale sur
les terrains ça c'est une chose
et puis derrière je voudrais insister
qu'on doit marcher sur deux jambes à la
question de la prévention
parce que le sujet par exemple des rixes
qui fait beaucoup à l'actualité en ce
moment et à juste titre parce qu'on est
confronté à un vrai problème de violence
chez des jeunes de plus en plus jeunes
en réalité pour prévenir ça et pas
simplement ensuite sanctionné parce que
ça ne règle pas tout il faut des moyens
sur le terrain pour les clubs de
prévention pour les associations qui
font le travail sur le terrain et ça
encore une fois ça passe par des moyens
financiers et là encore une fois la
droite n'est pas au rendez-vous et
valérie pécresse qu'est ce qu'elle a
fait dans les quartiers politique de la
ville ces diminutions par quatre des
moyens qui sont alloués à ces
territoires là donc voilà juste remettre
un peu en perspective les choses entre
le discours et la réalité
reda oui je pense que enfin il faut pas
non plus tomber un peu dans les ti chez
le plan borloo pour les banlieues c'est
pas la gauche de la gauche même si elle
n'a pas été appliquée il a été rejetée
d'un revers de main par emmanuel macron
c'était un bon plan d'ailleurs on a
beaucoup
le gloss même parfois des bonnes idées
d'élus de gauche comme il ya des bonnes
idées aussi de droite bien ce que je
disais moi mais en fait ce qui me frappe
c'est toujours l'association de la
thématique de la sécurité plutôt à la
droite parce que il va y avoir beaucoup
d'insistance sur cette thématique là
dans les médias mais moi j'aimerais
qu'on regarde derrière sur les faits sur
le terrain et là la droite ne fait pas
mieux que la gauche ça il faut quand
même se le dire une bonne fois pour
toute et le plan borloo nous on l'a
soutenu avec beaucoup de nos élus locaux
qui ont participé beaucoup
d'associations semblera matic que ça a
été balayée d'un revers de main par ce
gouvernement
je veux dire c'est le vrai sujet à mon
avis c'est aussi la constance voilà
parce qu'un plan comme le plan borloo
qui pour une fois ne fait pas que du
soutien par des subventions mais en même
temps que l'accompagnement humain dit on
casse on dessine un autre quartier parce
que il faut que l'habitat soit différent
moins concentré avec moins de problèmes
de voisinage avec plus d'équipements
plus de respiration plus de mixité aussi
et c'est évident qu'on va faire c'est en
2 enfin j'veux dire un plan comme le
plan borloo il nécessite que l'état
tienne parole pendant au moins cinq ans
sept ans et on est d'accord pour faire
le constat ensemble que la parole n'a
pas été tenue à chaque alternance
il ya un beau d'argent qui a disparu il
ya une partie de programmation qui a été
abandonnée revue retaper et pour les
acteurs de terrain c'est très désarmant
et là je parle d' élus locaux de toute
sensibilité des associations des
entreprises aussi qui parfois veulent
travailler dans ces quartiers s'y
installer par les zones franches
c'est très désarmant de voir qu'on vous
annonce un plan et que la mi-parcours
lille est en lambeaux d'autant plus
qu'il ya une vraie attente des français
sur ces questions de sécurité jérôme
fourquet de l'ifop
nous dit dans l'opinion on observe une
très forte demande de sécurité avec la
réédition de scènes de violences
urbaines dont vous parliez d'ailleurs il
ya un sentiment de perte de contrôle sur
le régalien l'impression que sa flotte
et la crainte d'une dislocation du pays
vous la partagez cette crainte gabriel
ses rires
on voit bien que le climat est tendu
effectivement alors il ya le fait qu'on
soit toujours confronté au terrorisme on
l'a vu encore ces derniers jours et puis
à le climat
sociale qui devient très très très dur
fin ça a été un quinquennat très très
difficile d'avec une distingue à la main
du pays ou pas le mot dislocation
allemand dislocation est très fort mais
je pense que ça fait référence aussi un
sentiment de peut-être
bah oui de division enfin si je pense
aux crises qui ont marqué ce quinquennat
c'est des crises de division très forte
et qui met en lumière des inégalités qui
crée en fait des séparations moi ce qui
m'a beaucoup frappé dans la crise des
gilet jaune c'était des questions
sociales mais c'était aussi des
questions d'inégalités territoriales
avec la mise en exergue deux territoires
dévitalisées qui se sentent délaissés
par rapport à des métropoles qui au
contraire concentre la richesse les
entreprises les services publics
et si on veut lutter contre ce sentiment
de dislocation moi mon sentiment et ça
doit passer aussi par les
investissements dont on parlait tout à
l'heure pour faire le lien avec le plan
b donne n'est pas d investissement fort
sur la question des transports le
maintien des petites lignes des
investissements qui doivent tenir leurs
promesses aussi de la part des
opérateurs pour régler la question des
zones blanches
on peut pas avoir l'impression si vous
voulez qu'il ya une france à deux
vitesses
aujourd'hui c'est ça qui est très
dangereux je pense lorena je pense que
vous savez un moment donné jacques
chirac avait fait sa campagne sur la
fracture sociale et je pense que le
sujet aujourd'hui ça la fracture
territoriale effectivement on le voit
avec les campagnes on le voit avec les
quartiers dans les métropoles
et ce qui est marquant surtout c'est
qu'en fait cette fracture territoriale
elle est en train de résumer les autres
fractures qui crée des inégalités
elle prend avec elle où elle prend en
elle cette fracture territoriale les
inégalités d'éducation et de réussite
éducative les inégalités d'accès à
l'emploi et de réussite professionnelle
les inégalités dans la vie quotidienne
la mobilité l'accès à la santé et puis
les inégalités aussi il faut il faut le
dire tout simplement dans l'ascension
sociale enfin je tiens la république
elle s'est bâtie quand même sur une idée
simple qui est que on peut s'échapper de
sa condition peut s'échapper ses
origines familiales ont poussé ça fait
deux saisons voilà l'émancipation de la
femme et de l'homme
par ses choix individuels son travail
c'est un échec aujourd'hui et c'est ça
qui est en train de tomber en panne dans
certains territoires et c'est ce qui
provoque cette réaction des français et
donc la sécurité n'échappe pas à la
fracture territoriale en fait je pense
que c'est ça qu'il faut dire avec
simplicité voilà ce qui se passe sur le
domaine de l'école de l'emploi du
respect de la personne de la promotion
dans la société existe aussi en matière
de ses clauses plus d'égalité pourrait
être égale à plus de ces crimes et
reconnaissait que dans l'égalité il ya
bien sûr l'égal accès à la sécurité et
et à une vie tranquille et sûr fin je
veux dire moi ça en tant que mère
c'était une de mes priorités évidemment
on peut pas en être autrement
bien sûr et à l'emploi bien sûr il ya
l'éducation c'est fondamental mais la
santé et le logement mais l'égal accès à
la sécurité au fait de se savoir en
sécurité
c'est indispensable et c'est vrai que
ses quartiers sur ce plan là les
premiers témoins sont sont les habitants
je vous le savez comme moi vous les
journalistes font souvent des reportages
les premiers à demander l'égalité en
matière de sécurité
ce sont les habitants de ces quartiers
et on s'arrêtera là merci à tous les
deux d'avoir participé à six matchs des
idées c'est donc la fin de cette
émission se retrouvent demain à 18
heures et à 22 heures 30 demain
également 7h30 vous retrouvez bonjour
chez vous au rayonnement de chez niro
sera notamment nicolas bay candidat du
rassemblement national aux régionales en
normandie je vous souhaite une
excellente soirée sur public sénat
revoir ce projet